what's been your biggest fear in all of
this or do you feel like you're pretty
fear proof at this moment I'm fear proof
because I'm willing to go to zero I
don't know what else to say like this is
pretty has proven it to me even more
I sent of me that thought while I've
been saying this for the last two years
am I fully has completely gone away like
I just beat her because I don't value
things and money like I know for a fact
that if I became a 100 full-time garage
sale Amazon flipper but I'd make a
million dollars a year I know that for
fact and that doesn't take into account
that I am that I built a brand and sure
my brand would take a hit if I all my
businesses went to zero but the reality
is America's funny man like there's
people following and helping O.J Simpson
there's you know Wolf of Wall Street
like this is a country that gives second
third four chances regardless and so
like I'm already at a place right now
where between brand and capability and
humility I'm bulletproof I believe
the biggest fear we have isn't failure
you're not afraid of failing the biggest
fear we have is of failing in front of
other people you're afraid of people's
judgments the reason why we stay stuck
the reason why you still are where you
are is because you're afraid of other
people's opinions you have
great ideas inside you you have great
ideas if you're watching this video
You're subscribed to this channel you
have great ideas you know you're capable
of more you know you want to serve you
know you want to help
and great ideas are flowing through you
and we shut them off
shut them off because we find a logical
reason why we can't do it right the
logical reasons in our head are well the
timing's not right or I don't have the
gear right on the connections or uh you
know I'm in the wrong country or
whatever logical excuse that we come up
with that's that's listen it's based in
reality it's actually based in fact
because you wouldn't you're a smart
person you wouldn't believe a stupid
reason
so the reasons that we're listening to
are actually based on some kind of fact
but they're still an excuse and
underneath it underneath that reason why
you can't do something is because you're
afraid
you're afraid I'm afraid we're afraid of
taking the next step and the fear
underlined that is not the fear of it
not working out it's the fear of it not
working out and who's going to see you
fail
we're so tied up into what other people
think about us that we'd rather play
small for life than actually go off and
accomplish and risk failing in front of
other people we're so afraid of that
that we never go off in
chase our dreams down and you're stuck
in this mental exercise of what you
could do
and then never actually doing anything
my biggest fear of disappointing people
you know it's that's still fear of
judgment it's still fear of I'm gonna
show up and speak in an event and it's
just not going to go well that that
people will
be unhappy with my speech and I put
a crazy amount of pressure on myself and
in my head I think people are here and
if I struggle then the whole thing is
ruined right I remember I was speaking
at friend of burchard's event and uh it
was in Puerto Rico and people are paying
tons of money to be here you know it was
a 30 to 50 000 Mastermind and
everybody's got giant businesses right
these are multi-million dollar
businesses owners who are in the house
and there's a multiple Day event I think
it was a three-day event and I'm I'm
speaking for one of them not even a
whole day I'm speaking I have one I've
got an hour or something of time right
at that event
in my head it's if I suck on stage then
people will freak out and be unhappy and
say this was a total waste of event
we're really I'm a really tiny nothing
part of this event event right I mean
people are there to see Brendan burchard
the scene Dean graziosi the sea the
other speakers there if any one speaker
sucks I mean if Brendan sucks that's a
big deal because he's speaking for 80 of
the time if I suck for one hour nobody's
really gonna care nobody's really gonna
be asking for a refund but
even though that's the the actual answer
it's not the it's not the thing that's
in my head and that's what we need to
fight that's what we need to fight
because I used to say no to
Opportunities because I was really deep
down just afraid that I would not be
able to deliver
I remember that I used to secretly hope
people would cancel on me
I would I would secretly hope that
interviews would cancel on me the
meetings would cancel on me
um
I remember I would book something out
like it's two months in advance right I
don't know if this has ever happened to
you this if this makes sense or if it's
happening to you let me know in the
comments
I would book something out that was a
month in advance or two months in
advance and so yeah I'm like that's
exciting I'm happy to do that and then
on the day of I look at my calendar and
say oh that's coming up and I would
secretly hope I would check my email I
remember I'd be checking my email hoping
that that person would cancel on me to
say oh I'm busy or I got sick or it's
not going to work out anymore and let's
reschedule and I remember I check in the
morning and I checked two hours of four
and check an hour before and check half
an hour before and check 10 minutes
before and like if there was no email
then then I would go ahead and do it
so I'm losing insane amounts of
productivity right like how many times
am I checking my email before this thing
happens lose an insane productivity and
also not actually serving right not
actually living my mission my message
not not actually being proud of myself
for what I'm doing and it
it almost always worked out like I never
had an interview or a meeting or
something where I just massively
underperformed and actually sucked right
that that never really happened but I
was always afraid of it happening and so
I had to teach myself
this is what I want to do like the only
thing worse than me not doing this
is is me doing this and canceling right
or them me never doing an interview and
me never doing a meeting
and just recognizing that it was just
fear talking and again the fears of me
disappointing people and failing in
front of somebody else
I'm sitting here filming in in the car
Nina just came back we love you Nina
Nina's uh doing some grocery shopping
and I'm filming here you know in the car
we got the dogs here in the back seat
timo's chilling and this used to make me
afraid you know that look there's a guy
who just pulled up next to me
she's not watching but in my head you'd
be like this guy's watching
you have to be afraid of filming in a
parking lot be afraid of filming uh
walking down the street I'd be afraid of
filming with my sister in the room you
know you should be afraid of all of that
so what is that
it's just fear of other people's
opinions why am I afraid of this guy
why I'm afraid of that guy I don't know
that guy
right
why am I afraid of him and his opinion
first off he doesn't even care right
he's not even looking at me he doesn't
even care maybe he never even noticed
that I was filming period right so we
think people care they don't care
on the off chance that he actually cares
uh maybe he is judging me and thinks I'm
crazy holding this camera up with with
the tripod in my hand maybe he thinks
I'm crazy great uh somebody's leading
with that then then they hate their own
life like if somebody's leading with
just negative judgment he's got his own
issues to deal with that have nothing to
do with me or maybe he's inspired maybe
maybe this guy goes look he pulled out
his phone maybe he's making his own
YouTube video maybe he's inspired maybe
that guy is now going to be the next
YouTube sensation let's go
so we assume that everybody's gonna
watch us everybody's only looking at us
and
and we're gonna disappoint and be a
giant failure and everybody's gonna
laugh for me to kill us right like
that's the thought that's that's in our
head where the reality is most people
don't care
[Music]
most people right like 90 of people
don't even care
five percent of people might judge you
and they're in a really negative spot
themselves and the other five percent
maybe they're inspired by you and they
see that and they go and do something
with their life
but you playing small and listen to that
fear instead of actually taking some
kind of action will always lead to a
negative spot like you know that you
could do more you want to do more you
want to serve on a bigger scale but
listening to that fear
instead is keeping you stuck this is one
of the biggest problems for
entrepreneurs is that you you have all
these great ideas that are flowing
through you right you've got you've got
an endless list of ideas how big is your
list of things that you could do that
you get excited by when you look at them
and then how many are you actually doing
well not very many you're missing the
momentum because at the end of the day
you could write down a list of all these
reasons why it can't work out and and
when the timing is going to be just
right and perfect right I'll start this
on January 1st or start this next month
or next week or Monday or my birthday or
some artificial day you come up with
some reason of when you should be
starting this thing right but if you
actually examined it if you actually
took a little step back and looked at
your goals that you haven't hit that you
haven't started that just remain an idea
and you've never taken momentum on if
you actually took five minutes to step
back from it create a little distance
and look at them
and look at your list of reasons why you
haven't started really it's just fear
and when you can catch that
that's when you make a life-changing
decision
because as long as you are
not chasing down the things that you
want to do because you're afraid of
somebody else's Judgment of you as long
as that is a thing that rules you you
will never win you will never accomplish
anything great and you'll you'll live
life with regret so even now my my
biggest fear is still disappointing
people
and the ongoing challenge is to catch it
and when you can catch it and when you
can know BS
catch it to say I'm just throwing up a
bunch of excuses but really I'm just
afraid when you can catch it
then
some of the courage to go do the
difficult thing summon the courage to
say I'm gonna I'm gonna take this fear
head on
because as long as that fear runs your
life
you stay stuck
and every time you catch the fear and
you do it because of not just feel the
fear and do it anyway Feel the fear and
do it because of
you start to teach yourself to be a
little stronger a little more courageous
and you move a little bit closer to
becoming the person that you are capable
of being
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there
let's not demonize technology which a
lot of people are doing because they
want to use it as an excuse to not do it
realize that technology is the gateway
to real interaction and your life will
change the biggest reason people are
unhappy right now is because they value
somebody else's opinion more than they
value their own that is the number one
blanket statement that I've got for
everybody your your mother's point of
view on you your wife's point of view on
you your your boyfriend's point of view
your homies point of view like the
reason I'm super happy is nobody can
tell me nothing
my wife mom and daughter can walk into
my room right now tell me I'm a piece of
crap and I would be 100 enthused that is
some gangster emotional structure and
that's why I can never lose I know who I
am and I just I'm unfazed so if my mom
daughter and wife could come in and tell
me I'm a piece of crap and I'm cool what
do you think that troll on Instagram
that says I suck does
nothing so you need to figure out the
following it is very likely that either
your mom or dad screwed you up
they made you insecure they didn't love
you enough they told you they you
weren't good because they weren't good
and misery loves company once you face
that demon once you cut out negativity
and the people that hold you down and
you surround yourself with positivity
and don't confuse delusion don't watch
my videos and rah-rah up and you don't
put any work in nothing good is gonna
happen you're just gonna watch my videos
so don't get it confused but life is
basic you're either on the optimism team
or you're on the pessimism team you're
other you're either on the offense or
you're on the defense the reason people
are unhappy is because let's talk about
money and unhappiness your three best
friends have a BMW and you don't you
think it's that you don't realize that I
loved when all my friends had BMWs and I
had nothing
expected man what are we doing here like
what are you valuing like what
everybody's on defense all the
immigration issues in the world nobody's
taking yours
they think some immigrants taking your
job you suck
like if you think that right do you
think somebody else is taking your spot
this is the world we live in the rich
Like You Know Rich this world in the UK
Market you live in the UK and you're
complaining
so so that's practical you you have a
family member or a childhood
that put you in a mindset of defense and
listen I know I'm gonna get a lot of
hits on Twitter and Instagram about this
interview now when I spit this because I
know a lot of people haven't heard of me
or have contacts on me let me just say
this
the answer to everything is and what now
right like I know people grew up in
alcoholic households I know people were
molested I know people had somebody
steal all their money here's my problem
nobody cares
like what are you waiting for like like
nobody's there is no fair fairy flying
down from the earth and saying you were
born an African-American in America
where that's an issue here's a million
dollar that's not happening so my thing
is instead of dwelling
and wishing how it was understand back
to the next practical part of your
question that the internet is now here
and guess what the internet's not a 76
year old white man it's the internet
and that means everybody's got a shot so
go take yours it's happening on YouTube
Facebook Instagram go figure it out
instead of being on it and thinking it
sucks and go get your money happiness
and that's it simple as that I got no
time for people complaining because it's
just not true anymore 1986 yes
2018 what do you think why do you think
me too is happening now the internet one
it's over the minimum amount of money
you want to make for your life like like
what would be the minimum amount of
money that you make every year that
allows you to live
and do that content media site what do
you think
maybe 40 50 000 pounds maybe great so
you're like what is amazing about that
if that's where you're at
well then at this young of an age and
that's where you're at and the fact that
you're even here and you know it's just
unbelievable amounts of content in
written audio and visual form on
Instagram Snapchat Facebook Twitter and
YouTube and podcast and I will tell you
I would be flabbergasted in three four
five six years unless you suck which you
may but if you don't suck and you have
that little of a financial need right
which is remarkable which is the biggest
thing somebody here I don't know if
they're here said you made me realize I
didn't need Rolexes and things of that
nature right like the biggest reason so
many of you will fail is your number for
success is far greater than his
you think you need a million
which will then mean that you're going
to do a lot of things when you don't get
a million very quickly that won't ever
get you a million
so if you if you think what I just said
is cool which is bleed for six years in
a row you'll probably get sponsorship or
sales of product to 40
000 a year
to me that's what I did I knew what I
wanted I was willing to give up my 20s
for it
came up
gave him up
you know somebody said it's difficult
not to document right now I'm like but I
but I didn't right but like what should
I build my business or should I document
I'm like both he's like well I gotta
pick one I'm like build your business
like so if you're if your Ambitions are
that humble which they are that's
incredible that excites me because by
the way here's the funny part that's who
I was too
I just needed a hundred thousand a year
just that seemed Rich to me right like I
was like cool
um I'll be okay like like I'll have a
house like you know it's not you know I
just needed to play I needed the game
and too many people too many of you in
here want the stuff not the game
when you fall in love with the game
everything's different because you've
already won that's real it sounds cliche
but it's real you find what you're
looking for I've been giving a lot of
thought to kind of just watching what
I'm seeing out there in the social
digital ecosystem and very honestly just
real life and I'm watching so many
people over the last two to three years
look for negativity look for something
that's wrong find where people disagree
with them fight look for what was me
downside to half glass empty and and
then I go to a Twitter search or look
around the world and I find ridiculously
beautiful things every day every day
thousands of kind acts randomly by
people all people that I have
conversations with who see the
opportunities whether it's in business
like voice and AR or crypto or whatever
it may be just this amazingly
interesting thing that I feel the
majority of you are looking for the
wrong while there's plenty wrong and
plenty of bright in the world it comes
down to one very simple thing what are
you choosing to look for because I
promise you if you right now and I'm
making this video for one reason 24
hours of trying to find the good
somebody saves a kitten somebody opens
the door somebody does a nice thing for
you [__] somebody says thank you 24
hours of looking for positivity could
change your life honestly making this
for one [__] person one one person
watches this video chooses to do 24
hours of looking for good instead of
looking for bad and their game changes
drock heard somebody at a convenience
store saying mom you're always so
negative you're always so negative I am
blown away by the fact that life gets
real simple if you break down into this
are you looking for the negative this
sucks this government sucks this person
sucks this is or you're looking for the
positive she's nice that's remarkable
I've got this opportunity
you choose what you're looking for
because what you look for you find
that's how life works I know you help a
lot of people start especially younger
people but how does a person with four
kids position right now doesn't like his
job yeah but just can't quit and sell
stuff yeah and find stuff in the
junkyard so if you're listening and
you're over 42 let's just use my age
um there's something interesting you
said something that I help a lot of
people that are younger it only has to
do with one thing they actually believe
in the technology we live in right this
room is filled with guys right now
who've taken advantage of YouTube or
Instagram or just the Facebooks of the
world and the only thing I need to do to
break through somebody who's 47 in the
suburbs of London who has a Mortgage
Debt and three children is for them to
understand that unlike when he or she
and I grew up and there was no internet
the thought of like having a happy life
was separate than taking care of what
you were supposed to take care of the
fact that everybody can come home
tonight at six seven eight nine pm and
then take out their phone or their iPad
or whatever and get to work for three
more hours and go to sleep at midnight
get their good six or seven hours of
sleep I'm not talking about don't sleep
a lot of people get me confused my big
thing is if you're not happy if you're
happy and you make 37 000 pounds a year
Mazel Tov do you but if you are not
happy if you hate your job right you can
do something about it instead of blaming
brexit or blaming Trump or blaming your
mom like do something about it and my
point is it's the internet today I lost
50 of all the money that I have people
are dishing me because they don't want
to go to the conference anymore so I've
been just full-on pissed right getting
on today yeah that sounds awesome well
today yeah I like it I like it I like it
I'll tell you why because I even I can
tell by your demeanor that you're gonna
be okay the fact that you realize that
that negative moment has positive of
impact the question is why did it happen
and that's why you have to be honest
with yourself
I don't know you know but that's you
know I'm pumped that you can have the I
mean you're more positive than half of
people here and it sounds like you're
having a terrible day
you know a super race that's why I
wanted to ask you how do you keep the
positivity in the colonists when
everything you're saying is because
basically when things happen I go the
other way
so tonight
I just was reminding myself every time I
every time you came and the next person
came I was just reminding my literally
in my own head saying you don't mean I
said it to one of you I said they said
how do you stay humble
whenever you're so successful I'm like
because I know if I die tomorrow I'll
have a good day on social media
like most comments ever on my latest
post on Instagram everybody's gonna be
like oh that was the last one weird and
and I know that all of you will be on
with your life a week later
you have to balance your ego with
humility in the same way when I'm having
my worst day I realize I'm the best
I'm gonna be the best that ever does
this
and so the way I handle things is when
something's going one way I use all my
emotional strength to push the other way
what are you gonna cry for the rest of
your life because the conference got
[__] up
like I just like to me it's just like
look what the [__] guys if you're in
this room right now let me just remind
you that there are 7.7 billion people
literally right now as we stand here
there are women being shipped to be
strippers
in parts of our world right now as we
stand here there are women who are
basically caged mentally usually and are
being shipped to dance on a pole in
Manhattan and in London like do you
understand what's there's there's
genocide going on right now like what do
you think is going on
like we lack perspective your conference
got [__] up boohoo I lost a client
boohoo there's people dying out there
like like so when Americans or Europeans
talk to me about race or gender I'm sad
it's the real life but I remind them
because it's a positive thing cool but
let me tell you about the person that's
ranked seven billion in the world
they [__] have it bad
and so I just I struggle like I want to
like I I listen I'm weird I think about
things like animals like I don't know
like if you're the best elephant we are
still better than you
you know like
like listen you know I got hot on this
about a year ago though 400 trillion to
one it's impossible to be a human being
you won
I don't know how to get upset after that
I keep [__] in perspective right like
you're going to learn from this you've
[__] up
I promise you it's failing because of
you
and and when you start owning your and
not blaming other people and I think
this is the kick I've been on lately on
Instagram right like blame yourself you
know why I'm always happy I believe
myself
when you blame yourself for real you're
gonna always be happy
because you don't feel like somebody
else controls you my big ambition is to
be an all-time entrepreneur by both my
success and my career but uh what has
become more evident to people I think
recently is also by influencing as many
people as possible in a positive way so
that they get theirs
um and that means the person that goes
from the job that they're not excited
about to making 84 you know thousand
Sterling a year being happy talking
about their proper football team on
Instagram and YouTube to the young gal
right now in Sweden who's going to start
a 500 million dollar you know media
company so I think to be the great
entrepreneur of this generation uh
there's clearly the bezoses and and the
Elon musks and the zucks I don't think
I'm going to be able to create that kind
of wealth uh I just want to create
obnoxious amount of wealth uh but you
know a billion dollars and a billion
people I think puts you above everybody
else and and I I think that is where my
behavior is right now like why am I
doing this podcast for Venus boosts the
media yeah the book yeah so she's
podcast yes you do a lot yeah man look
here's what I think I think we get one
at bat
um the number one thing that scares me
in life is Regret I really really really
don't want to be on my deathbed whether
that's tomorrow or when I'm 97 and think
I should have done that I should like
that's that Spooks me right like hard
work people judging me leaving you know
trolling me on social media like all the
stuff that normal people worry about I
don't worry about I worry about regret
and so I'm trying to squeeze everything
out of my life and so yeah I do a lot
how did you say you know okay it might
be on Twitter in two years old how do
you go about finding that underpriced
attention and how do you know it's
underpriced too many of you in here have
ego around your time when it's the only
thing you got
so the reason I always know is because I
work
because I work
I work I try things I test I DM you back
I sweet I work
so when you're in
you taste it and when you've done it for
20 years you see patterns
Facebook's still underpriced you just
can't Target 22 to 25 year old
African-American fans of football
because other people are doing that too
now it's just like Google early on you
could just Target soccer
one word five cents a click I did it
wine
but then I had to put at the end of the
game now I got to put 2013 you know
Heller sellers Zinfandel like long tail
real estate
if you're right about London look it's
my favorite do you know what do you
understand that somebody once bought
this building for a dollar
somebody bought the land we're on for a
dollar once that happened it's a long
time ago
how do you know you're a practitioner
the reason I do is to how I learn you
got to put out all of you were like well
I can't do podcasting and Facebook and
Twitter oh but I can't I can Vlog but I
can't why
if you want it so bad
my thing is why if you want it so bad
why can't if you want to have a media
company around Caribbean food culture
why can't you I wanna you know what I
want to see I want to see all your
minutes
I want to see all your minutes I want to
give you drock for the day I want to
watch you from the moment you wake up to
the moment you go to sleep let me
promise you something you're gonna get
exposed
so so that's why daily B happened
because you guys like a lot of you
didn't know me before daily B how many
people knew me before dailyvee well not
bad right
you got you got to really know me post
daily B yeah you heard hard work and
hustle before you were confused
and I've been doing that every day for
20 years like I wasn't born six foot
seven and can run like a cheetah I could
wish I was something or I could realize
I am something and try to try to
maximize on that it's a game of poker
you get a hand
nobody's gonna cry for you about your
hand nobody's gonna say oh it's terrible
that you're not fast or tall or gorgeous
or tightly or or can sing it is what it
is and now the only thing that can
happen
is you can figure out how to navigate it
the second you stop dwelling and the
second you stop start doing everything
changes they don't give a [__] the
second you understand that and just
start trying to make it happen with that
energy you win I'm 26.
um I want to be uh I I want to say a
marriage counselor and finding that
every time I mention that like oh you
know uh what do you want to do with your
life and I tell people this
um there are instant response is you
know how are you going to do that you're
not married
um
my parents are divorced as if I was
eight since I was eight
um I'm not married I can I can answer
your question right away we're going to
build an amazing yeah we're going to
build an amazing case study together I'm
going to give you I'm going to give you
three names
um and then you're gonna cruise into the
sunset of success which is let's figure
out the three most successful coaches in
the history of sport that everybody
knows of that didn't play that sport
Bill Belichick even though I hate him
with all my guts did not play football
he grew up in the football game right
his dad and what was a coach or what
have you but Bill Belichick did not play
football and he will probably
unfortunately go down as the greatest or
if not one of the greatest head coaches
of all time you don't have to be listen
I think you have to be people have to be
thoughtful I hate 22 year old life
coaches that haven't lived life but if
they if they speak about here's my life
experiences and and why you can
eliminate though very quickly the art
when somebody says to you but how are
you gonna you can't do let me first of
all a couple other questions are your
friends and your circle telling you you
can't do that or are customers that
you're trying to do that with telling
you that they don't want to go with you
because you're not married
uh no this this is more acquaintances uh
people you know that I run into yeah so
listen that's something listen that's a
mistake
like you can't listen to acquaintances
their opinions don't matter
okay you can't listen to film half you
you can't listen
yeah
no go ahead I'm sorry I'm getting
excited you should talk go it looks like
am I I'm like huh
um basically like I I wanna because I I
follow you and I've been following you
for a couple years now and I do agree
what you have to say about education I
do think people are gonna start moving
from you know going to school and
setting their kids to school to finding
I got you I've got your answer I've got
your answer and a lot of people get up
you know what I'm gonna ask of course I
know I know exactly where you're going
so if you're not gonna get the PHD
there's only a few ways to justify
and gives confidence to the End Market
what what why they would jump with you
it's crazy to me that so many people I
was watching 60 Minutes last night in
the background as I was working and the
way that Oprah was justifying the person
was he has a PHD in this and a masters
in that even 60 Minutes use those pieces
of paper to create author Authority in
our society pieces of paper from
businesses and that's what colleges are
has been the authority the only other
people that get Authority are the people
that have gone out and done it and have
people co-signing them right makes sense
so the way and this is why I love
working for free when you don't have a
piece of paper right one of the reasons
I love working for free is working for
free for somebody who is that person in
society whether they got a piece of
paper or their Puff Daddy and they just
did it
becomes the equity that you trade under
once you become great at something right
Andy Andy who's sitting here right now
had every single famous person I see
gives him a lot of street cred right
away not because he got a
degree for personal branding and
marketing for Virginia Tech what degree
did you get political science not
because of his
political science degree from Virginia
Tech but because he went and worked
underneath me and I went out and did it
and I always give him love and Good
Vibes the end
it's not Babin's degree from the USC
School of film or NYU
jumped out
you know so so what you need to do and
what you need to do is one of two moves
if you're not gonna go get a PhD and
have everybody comfortable with it you
either need to go work for somebody that
is the authority and ask all thousands
of people that are authorities and work
for them or okay you need to give your
services for free to five couples crush
it for them and use their word of mouth
and endorsements and uh as your leverage
Point once you've got the money yeah and
you get your first paycheck and you're
like you know what I've got some money
in the bank now where do you go to then
build that money I think the reason you
feel right now is about a year ago I got
into the whole mindset of like oh crap
there's a lot of people watching me who
have zero so I started talking about the
flip Challenge and go to Craigslist but
in general most of my career was talking
more about people that had a little
something that's a very easy place for
me I think the answer to you or anybody
who's listening is what do you want to
happen in life I want to buy the New
York Jets American football team I've
got to be on on the offense you know but
if you have a little bit of money and
you don't want to work super hard for
the rest of your life and you don't have
ambition for all-time Legacy well then
you should put your money into Facebook
and Amazon stock and watch it grow over
the next 20 years and buy yourself a
nice little College Cottage in the
country when you're done the answer to
your question is completely 100
predicated on your ambition
what is the ambition that you have if
you want to buy a Premier League team
you better go on the offense and pour
every one of those dollars back into
hyper upside if you want to just chill
and and smoke weed in Ibiza well then
you don't have to why do you hate
Fridays so much because I hate people
that live their lives for the weekend
Way by people celebrating the end of the
week
like the weekend is your escape from
your reality it breaks my heart my
friends like live for Friday night like
they know they get the week like Monday
morning is the worst to live your life
where you love Friday night Saturday and
Sunday and despise Monday through
Thursday or Friday morning is
devastating to me because you're wasting
too much of your life like 50 of your
entire life is predicated on what you do
at work like it's just a huge percentage
of one's life and I'm trying to put
pressure on the conversation to say if
you love Friday that much then you need
to really look at Monday through
Thursday and see if you can do something
about it Sunday night I'm like chomping
I'm like a fighter before a fight like
in the dressing room like I can't like I
try to go to sleep early on Sunday
because I can't wait for Monday because
I get to put my jersey on this is not
your grandpappy's life we have the
internet you can make [__] happen you
can build businesses or side hustles
take less money
live a little more humbly to set up your
next 50 years so many of you are so
hungry for short-term short-term gains
like maximizing the job that paid you
three thousand dollars more but it's not
as fun but you want that three thousand
dollars for what
for what for a new iPhone for what live
life one time I'm talking about if you
genuinely dislike what you do so much
that you begged for Friday listen I
lived 12 years of this and definitely at
least nine I just don't understand why
people relegate into losing mentality
and just thinking they can you can't
because you want to be on the bowling
team or softball and play video games
that's why you can't there's plenty of
time getting done
technology and the way we live doesn't
care about my opinion or my feelings and
it doesn't care about yours either and
so you can walk around Earth and judge
oh it's so sad that all these kids can't
communicate because they're on the phone
anymore and you could talk about a day
and age when it was simpler and nicer
and all this nobody gives a
[Music]
and if you don't adjust to the reality
of the situation you will be completely
left behind too many people are
executing or hoping or trying to figure
out how to live in a world that used to
be or the way they wish it was versus
attacking the reality of the world and
here is the reality of the world my
friends
the cell phones that you're all holding
right now or in your pocket are the
remote controls of our society they are
the single most important thing in the
world there's nothing close whatever you
want to happen in life you first need
somebody's attention and then you need
to tell them about it it was called the
newspaper the television and the radio
now it's called a Blog a vlog or a
podcast it's the same thing nothing's
changed except one thing your attention
is moving to a new place and leaving an
old place I'm making this very simple
very black and white very basic if you
do not spend next year completely
obsessing over how you become successful
on Facebook and Instagram you will be
disproportionately less likely to win
the ad product on those two platforms
are disproportionately underpriced
and that that is where you should be
trading you are grossly underestimating
what's happening right now
98 of people are grossly underestimating
how good it is right you will look back
at this talk all my content during this
era why am I producing so much content
during this era why am I flying around
the entire world over and over speaking
to this subject it's because I know what
I'm talking about right now is gonna go
away
and I think we can all agree I'm not
hedging up here right now
I'm desperately trying to force this
down your mouth
right
you heard it
and I believe that 95 of you will not do
anything about it you'll do enough to
make it feel like you did something
and you will regret not going all in how
many people here play poker
good I don't but if you do
when you have the best hand it's a good
idea to go all in I absolutely know I
will be the greatest entrepreneur of
this era because I'm going to win on the
two fronts that people are going to
judge by I'll make enough money so that
I'm in the conversation
and I will inspire and help more
entrepreneurs than the rest of the field
combined I'm talking all of them because
what Elon Musk does in his actions to
inspire is incredible it's incredible
and Steve Jobs and but what I'm doing is
different and I know it
the end
because and by the way it's because I
want it more right it's not that I'm
better I just want that that's the part
I want
I'm it's what this whole thing is that's
why the document like people don't even
understand what I'm actually doing I'm
leaving so much like from a businessman
I'm leaving so much money on the table
right
right but money is not the goal no you
know what's funny for me money stopped
being a goal at a hundred thousand
dollars
I couldn't believe I made a hundred
thousand dollars a year right I was like
that was it
and since then nothing's been the same
it doesn't feel the same
not a million not 10 million doesn't
feel the same 100 000. the number one
mistake that people are making in life
today and it's and it's just so
unbelievably obvious is they're living
life in the middle
you know 99.9 of the people that watch
or listen to this content are living in
the middle they're they're hedging and
making excuses and justifying why they
are not 100 happy it's because like
every other person out there besides a
few select people they are living in
this middle ground and I just say the
middle and when I think about how you
win in business in entrepreneurship but
most of all in life it's by
understanding the macro and micro
opportunities and executions if you
really understand how to break through
how to be in that zone how to really
really really win the game it comes down
to a strategy that looks like this are
you balancing your ego with your
humility are you balancing your ego with
your humility do you equally think that
you're the greatest of all time and you
can do it and that also you're a piece
of and nobody cares when you're gone I
really see that there's so few people
that take advantage of what's out there
because a lot of people hear that stuff
and think it's more like the secret like
you just sit and you dream it into
existence right right it's got a very
interesting stigma listen I for example
as you know don't love positioning
myself as a motivational speaker even
the content you just saw but no question
the mindset is the operating system of
our lives and I'm an absolute believer
in cutting out negativity going on the
offense like positive thinking like
what's the alternative like practicality
I'm a big believer in that stuff but
action is really the biggest thing huh
it ha and and I do believe that the
right mindset leads to the right actions
um so yes I do think you've listened to
me it's about getting poisoned out of
the system right right I mean look how
many people lose in your situation yeah
yeah right yeah because that's what they
decide to think about right you did it
right the end right it's a binary right
and so you know one of the things I do
often is the people around me about
negativity I'm like What's the
alternative there's so much negative
there's like this scares the [__] out of
people right you're positive they're
running around with their legs and
complaining right right so I'm with you
I couldn't agree more just for the fine
things in life for the bottles and the
models and the private planes I think
You're Gonna Lose and it definitely is
not my definition of an entrepreneur and
my definition about entrepreneur is
somebody who can't live without doing
their thing and trying to create
literally suffocated for me I think that
that's what's amazing about anything
which is there's many different uh many
different uh definitions for you uh you
know go out work your face off win and
reward yourself with something is
exactly right for me the reward is
pouring more of the dollars and energy
into the company not buying stuff for
myself it's one and the same yeah it's
one in the same I don't I don't judge
you know I talk a lot about like stop
posting cash and Lamborghinis and
private jets not because I don't think
one deserves it after they work hard
it's that so many of the people on
Instagram that are posting that are
fronting
I mean they're like literally driving to
a private plane pad taking the photo and
then driving home they're they're fully
and so to me I I think it's amazing if
somebody wants to buy an Armani suit or
a five thousand dollar pair of a belt or
a diamond ring for a hundred thousand I
don't but that doesn't mean that's right
or wrong what I'm doing with that same
hundred thousand instead of a ring is
I'm hiring two more people because I'm
trying to buy the jewelry company not a
piece of the jewelry I think reputation
is based on truth and so in today's
world where there's nowhere to hide
instead of hiring a PR person in 1994
and getting the right articles I think
it's just delivering crush it for your
employees crush it for your clients and
and fundamentally give without
expectation you know go give a keynote
at a college with no expectation answer
those 10 emails of people reaching out
to you that have nothing to offer you
and just give because you they actually
may have a ton to offer you what I love
is that reputation is becoming a more
transparent game and so the only way to
build a reputation is to do the right
things so over deliver for the ones that
have something or the ones that don't
have something uh way too many
entrepreneurs are way too calculated
about what's in it for me if you can
reverse that and think about what's in
it for them you'll find out that a lot
of things are in it for you I'm a big
believer that it's no different than
swimming or riding a bike two things
that didn't come natural to me I started
swimming and riding a bike late in my
life you know like I don't think I
started swimming until I was nine
because I feared them yeah
um but the answer was literally to just
jump in the pool and start swimming to
just like skin your knee right to take
in a little water you know fail a little
I just think you do it like I just like
I think the best thing that could happen
to you is if you hear this advice
there's a networking event in town you
go you put on your nice little Mainer
media Henley name tag you walk up you
see somebody you're inspired by my five
minutes with Gary you go up and go high
to John and John looks at you and says
get the [__] out of my face I actually
think that would be the best thing that
could ever happen to you yeah I think
the best thing that can happen to
somebody when they fear something is for
them to taste the thing they feared
aggressively and immediately when they
could try something
I think that it just eliminates like
you'll literally be there and whether
you go crying in the bathroom or just
like becoming silent or walking out of
there or walking and getting a you know
a you know a cheeseburger for five
seconds and coming back I think the
great thing that would happen to you is
that you'd be like okay well that
happened now what
like once people understand and taste
the thing they fear it becomes a hell of
a lot less scary you're so confident so
sure of yourself but when you were just
starting my mom your mom my mom what'd
she do for you when I was nine years old
and opened the door for an elderly woman
at a McDonald's
she reacted as if I won the Nobel Peace
Prize
good mom well my mom did was super smart
she overreacted on everything that I was
doing that was a good human trait and
she held me accountable for things that
didn't matter like grades my mom built
huge self-esteem in me and I feel like
the biggest reason I am who I am today
to everybody is because I feel so guilty
and so grateful for what she did for me
that I want to do it for everybody else
which is guess what you suck at a ton of
good so does everybody else you're also
probably pretty rad at something try as
many things as possible until you figure
out what you're rad at and you like and
go do that for the rest of your life and
stop giving everybody else one theme
that I really people are like yo how do
I build my self-awareness how do I build
my optimism how do I change my mindset
it's the people around you if your best
friend is Debbie Downer you're not going
to be as optimistic as you can be if the
people that from your town that you hang
out with have no ambition you're going
absolutely nowhere if you listen to your
dad every day about how the government
sucks you're not gonna love life you've
got to audit Your Inner Circle podcast
friends listen to me listen very
carefully to this mashup and these
thoughts because this underlining tone
of who you surround yourself with at
absolutely fundamentally changes who you
are period end of story when I hang out
with Silicon Valley in 2005 to 2010 I
was a different dude when I hang out in
the agency land right now I'm a
different dude when I'm like it when I
was in college at Mount Ida different
dude like you're a different person and
I'm telling you right now this morning
podcast or this podcast because I know
some of you listen to it late this
podcast if I can get one of you one
person listening to this to dump one
loser person in their Circle and add one
whoever's that smiley happiest person at
work that you don't talk to that much
that's at the cubicle around the way or
that awesome like that for you know how
everybody has like you have a friend but
their friend like went to college with
them you don't really know them but like
the three times you see them a year
they're positive
and like the doing things surround
yourself with those people seek out your
friend's friend who brings Positive
Vibes and make them part of your world
and cut out your homie from college that
thinks the world sucks watch with that
addition and subtraction does to your
life how are you
what's your name
Lisa how you doing I'm good good okay so
me my I want to become um an author okay
just like you amazing and I have been
writing it's my passion and I have I had
applied to this writing um YC team and I
spilled my heart out it was just me it
was wrong yes
they declined me yeah so it's like
it's like they yeah I get it it's like
that's me yeah it's like they're not
accepting me them but it's like
you know honestly guys first of all they
didn't decline you one random person
that read your declined you them
but it's like imagine if I train some
stuff up if I change me they would have
probably took me you're wrong you're
wrong listen to my face I'm telling you
right to your face you're wrong you're
valuing somebody else's opinion too much
you're wrong
this is not this is not a debate wrong
do you understand you're letting one
random person listen do you understand
how many people would have hired me none
okay who's who's got Instagram in here
cool go to it right now please do me a
huge favor go to Instagram go to garyvee
that's my account go 10 11 Post back
you'll see my report card I was ranked
243rd out of 254 in my class
43 out of 254 in my class you know why
because I knew it was
for me it might not be for you this is
about self-awareness you have to know
who the [__] you are but for me it was
because I didn't need it because I
wasn't I didn't give a [__] Saturn how
many rings Saturn had
listen to me you can't let something be
valuable more than you you're pandering
to them let them come to you take that
same essay and post that on Instagram
with a photo and see what happens
see what happens let the market decide
not some middle management person that
read you good
course it's true and when you're young
and 13 and 15 and 9 you think you got to
change up because you don't know how
it's played that's why I'm here to tell
you exactly how it's played one person
read your story my dear and that person
how do you balance clouds in the dirt
and which do you focus on more and why
so to find everybody how I Define clouds
and dirt clouds to me is like the why
the strategy the macro the big thinking
the big picture the operating system of
like how you do things and then the dirt
is having the humility to go to these
meetings to actually I post on my
Instagram photos the doing the the
humility ego humility strategy execution
clouds and dirt uh the way I balance it
is they're both important at all times I
can swing back and forth to them I can
literally go from a meeting where like
the call I had on the way out to our
first meeting here today Purell was with
vaynermedia's c-suite about a
restructuring of how we handle all our
business
super meta and they're literally hung up
and I posted something on Instagram and
wrote all the copy as we were walking
into our last meeting to me I balanced
them by doing whichever one is needed at
the time and so I don't think about it
as balancing it I think about it as time
allocation like what should I be doing
with my time and I think that you know
you made a joke of like we did a shoot
for a client and we debated on the phone
for 10 minutes where the
should be located for that I think
that's being in the middle right I think
uh pandering to the way companies do
things we just had a meeting where
they're like oh that was provocative us
as
um as the gallery Media Group holds and
all the other things we do us doing what
every other publishing does company does
is not a good idea that's the middle
that's not going to get you to the next
place and so for me I'm just in the
mindset of you know do either doing
humble Dirty Work like the reason I am
the best strategist in social media
out there I really believe this is
because I do both I both sit at the top
of a media company that really does it
at scale for the biggest companies world
but at the same token there's very few
humans that put out a hundred
40 pieces of content by hand a week and
reads the car I mean I literally just
replied to Kyle in my comments who and
I'm going to show you because I don't
think you guys believe me when I do
these rants I literally just replied to
Kyle one second before Babin's like
let's do this video like literally what
I was doing one second before then was
replying
to like literally like literally hearted
Kyle's comment of I'm digging the recent
pics and quotes man right like
many many people watching here would
argue that my time at this point in my
career of reading Kyle's comment and
Harding it in that minute was a bad use
of my time I think the dirt
is the reason why I come up with such
good clouds being in the trenches drives
my strategy I live in reality and
practicality not in thesis or ideology
or reading headlines or reading about
people doing marketing uh so I don't I
don't balance it I just do whatever is
needed at that second
Mac you know it's back to macro micro
micro speed I'm just always doing
something
right Bobby like that is the big
breakthrough everybody on the team says
like there's just every second is and so
the reason I can do something every
second is and I don't watch a YouTube
video or stand by the water cooler and
talk about the Rockets game for 10
minutes is because I always value the
dirt and so in that half a second that I
had right now in the transition of the
call that I just had about a macro
vaynerx strategy
right the second transition I had before
I started doing a macro thing like the
Vlog
was Harding Kyle's two cents on my last
Instagram post clouds and dirt I was
really an unusual Eastern European
immigrant that came during that time
every one of my friends uh every one of
my parents friends kids were straight A
students because education was the way
out if you go to Instagram literally
right now and look at my account garyvee
two posts ago I posted my high school
report card because nobody believes me
but I was a straight dnf student
somewhere around fourth grade I realized
that Saturn was not going to impact my
life and I didn't care about it and so
[Applause]
self-awareness is a son of a you know
and and and and honestly besides health
for everybody in this room I wish you
self-awareness because once you
understand who you are you can do a lot
of damage all of us suck at a lot of
stuff all of us are good at a lot of
stuff the game is to figure that out I
through good parenting through
circumstance through who knows really
what got very self-aware very early in
my life and listen at 13 you know listen
it was tough for my friend's parents to
say I was a loser because I got these
and F's it wasn't fun for my teachers to
say that I wasn't going to amount to
anything here was my biggest problem I
was 13 years old I was making three
thousand dollars a weekend selling
baseball cards I had 47 000 in cash
under my bed and I wasn't selling weed I
thought I was amazing you're asking
different questions you're asking when's
the time to jump in the pool when's the
time to kiss the boy when's the time you
know to get married you know you're
talking about like when's the time
taking training wheels off the bike you
know when's the time to live your life
that that's probably why I made content
the answer is I don't know nobody knows
there's no right answer there's that
moment in time yeah
this is why I produce content every day
it you might be watching my content
every day and it might be this
conversation with us in the Vlog that is
you know it's very meta this might have
been the one this might have been the
one on this day because of a
conversation you had last night because
of the the weather outside because of a
news headline
because of the patterns of how the four
Instagram posts came in your feed yeah
it might just be the time you finally do
what they're supposed to do and I think
a lot of people think of it as like quit
your job and go do your journey right
things you're thinking about others
I think of it a little bit different
sometimes it's
impractically that's exactly right
sometimes it's like um
I've been doing this nightlife and
t-shirt thing for seven years why don't
I go work for something smart for a year
reset why don't I uh go travel why don't
I sell my home that I don't use 90 of
take that money get an apartment and
then do something with them so to me
it's not just like the fancy Sizzle of
like
now jump into the rest of your life it's
also like it's also like audit
understand what you need break up with
that person marry that person you know
you know start your career go back to
corporate for an hour AKA year or two to
reset like you know
just do yeah it's the indecisism it's
the indecisiveness that is the poison
because you can always undo yeah
the biggest thing about doing is the
undoing that people don't see yeah I'm
always like
okay good and then like if you fail go
back but people don't want The Scarlet
Letter they don't want the Judgment this
is why you have to tune everything out
because if you can go and judge start
your t-shirt brand or your PIN brand or
your video blog and it fails if you just
think you can go back to it well that
sounds cool but if you feel like oh but
then everybody's got a clown on me and
see say like then you're if you're if
you're pessimistic moms will be like see
I told you you could never do it if you
can't get over that yeah then it's stuck
and I think there's an enormous amount
of confusion in the system for 28 year
olds about where they are in life I
think yeah that's that's my biggest
problem I've been having like and that's
I've been watching a lot of you and
watching a lot of your videos and a lot
of things that you do and all kinds of
other stuff and it's helped me kind of
come out and realize you know my time is
is when I ever find it I got my own
clock 100 bro honestly no joke I feel
like you're closer to 2.8 years old than
the way you think about 28 like you've
got 60 years of execution in front of
you that's like two full life's more of
execution and and the problem with 28 is
28 is a tricky thing 28 tricky 28 is too
many people up because I'm telling you
that looking at 30 like wait a minute's
like oh 30's here shouldn't I quote
unquote have my life together you know
and then at 28 you got you know five to
fifty percent of your friends that you
went to high school or college with that
are like you know getting married having
you know get getting somewhere in their
life don't let anybody else's clock you
know dictate your game dude honestly but
I'll shoot if Ray two I'm 42 years old
and I swear on everything I've got I
feel like I'm just starting and
everything that people think I am and
what I've accomplished and all that is
in my own head because I'm like I
haven't even started so imagine what I
think about you at 28. my entire career
what what allows me to be here today
what allows me to dream and be audacious
about owning a professional football
team is very simple I chase underpriced
attention I chase properly priced
attention and I completely punt
overpriced attention
simple I know that everybody in this
room does things for eight to ten hours
a day every day of the day of the week
the month the year on things that no
longer bring as much value as it did 6 9
14 years ago that helped you get to this
point I know that there's somebody in
this room that if they started a B2B
podcast
I know that if somebody in this room who
had never thought about producing
content or media if they started a
podcast which they don't even have the
beginnings of a thought of how to do
that right now but the good news is you
literally go to Google and you type in
how do I start a podcast
I know that if somebody here started a
podcast for this industry and put out an
episode every week and interviewed a
thought leader in this industry that
even though only 700 to 1500 people
would listen to it because it's
obviously very niche in its content that
it would be the differentiator of
growing their business that it would
lead to lead gen that there are people
that they're trying to chase to get the
account that in turn a year later would
be chasing them to be a guest on the
show which then would inevitably lead to
them getting the business my friends
please understand over the next period
of time as I talk to you about some of
these nuances that I am not a
technologist
that had I not been in business that I
wouldn't want to have necessarily an
Instagram or SnapChat or LinkedIn
account it doesn't come natural to me
it's not necessarily what I want what I
want is to sell stuff what I want is to
run a successful business what I want is
to win and to me if you sit in this room
and you do not realize how extreme
the internet technology Revolution
actually is you become vulnerable You're
not going to change Evolution and
Technology you just need to figure out
how to write it so it doesn't kill you
and by the way I mean this um you know
collecting the energy of the room
thinking about what we talk about here I
mean this I don't think it's bad
if you're not capable or willing to up
your game put in the work
hustle you should lose
it's how you won
but everybody
fights hard for 30 years and then wants
to hold up athletes you know you know
what I hate about business that I love
about athletes when you're the best
athlete in the world you get the results
when you get to 36 and a younger lion
comes along you lose
in business we have this weird
that we're supposed to be rewarded at
the end you
I mean it
you you didn't take this internet
serious for the last 20 years why the
[__] did you be rewarded pay the
attention to who's giving you the advice
because when you listen to outside
voices you're always going to regret it
my question is very simple would you
rather appease the inconvenience right
now
in the short term or do you want to sit
around as a 78 year old and regret how
you live your life that's the basic
question are you willing to take the
short-term lack of Pain by conforming to
the system or do you actually want to do
something with your life because this
internet thing the fact there's three
cameras in this room right now the fact
that a million people almost on
Instagram follow you like like that this
is available there's so much funding if
you're trying to reach the decision
maker at a retail organization that guy
or gal is also the same person that I
want to reach to sell a bottle of wine
or a book to and that space in his and
her Facebook feed is only one space
so that is supply and demand I used to
buy that space four years ago for a
dollar for every thousand Impressions
now it's seven the longer you think this
world doesn't exist and you fear
Margaret the longer you don't put money
in the longer I can extract all the
value I've lived this game I'm not a
hero because I took it from 3 to 50
million 60 million my dad's business I
actually am a schmuck I should have
spent more on Google
I had it figured out every time you
typed in Cabernet Merlot Silver Oak
Camus Napa Bordeaux I was showing up
first because nobody realized it was
good real estate and it was only costing
me five or ten cents a click and I was
making between seven and eighty dollars
in profit for something that was costing
me three dollars to get you through the
funnel on the average of 60 people
coming and one converting I was stupid
I'm being serious with you
I stand here and have passion about
LinkedIn and Facebook marketing in a B2B
environment today out of regret for what
I did from 2002 to 2005 because I should
have spent more it was basic math but I
just didn't understand
because I was young in my career and it
just I don't even know how to explain it
to you when it's too good to be true
it's too good to be true right I'm an
immigrant I was cynical I just didn't
plus I also thought it was important to
do direct mail and local commercials and
magazine I was doing it all but in
hindsight it was the great mistake of my
career
the great mistake of my career was not
spending more money on Google and I
promise you the great mistake of your
accelerated growth for the 80 that just
raised their hand is not taking
advertising on LinkedIn and Facebook
seriously because you don't think your
person is on it the biggest reason I
think people are struggling with social
media literally people are pandering to
a like on an Instagram post not on
necessarily what they're trying to do so
I think first and foremost at a macro
you need to understand are you actually
building your business to sell it
because then you may care about you know
the ebitda and how much profit you're
making and so that advice is important
vaynermedia is going to do 170 million
dollars and I'm not gonna make a penny
like I'm trying to pour it all back in
literally we may make zero profit this
year and it's because I don't want to
sell it tomorrow and I don't need the
dividends from the profits in a year to
change my lifestyle so I mean this it's
really important you have to know what
you're doing if someone wasn't raised in
that environment that self-belief how
does one develop that for themselves
surrounding themselves by people that do
it for them or consuming content that
does it for them
trading people's skulls and reframing
their games
the mom told him they were loser I'm
telling them we're a winner I think I
can out Market their mom their mom had a
big head start and a whole lot of like
emotional like physiological advantages
but guess what give me 18 months of your
time give me two hours a day
I'll make you realize your mom and go do
your thing
that's what I'm up to I made content
every day
for nine years before it started really
happening
see it's just basic but it works
and you've got this you've got craft
and there's a lot of people that have
craft so you have to chip chip chip you
know one day one post something cool and
somebody cool
Drake sees it does it and everything
changes yeah but you have to do it every
day to have that moment I was born in
Belarus in the former Soviet Union I
came to the U.S when I was three we
lived a very humble beginning as you can
imagine the economy wasn't super great
we didn't speak English we had a hundred
bucks uh I lived with seven family
members in a studio apartment in Queens
so it was super humble as you and you
know obviously my parents are very much
my heroes uh one because my mom is the
greatest parent of all time and two
because my dad worked his face off and
even though I slept under the same roof
literally every day of my life with my
dad in the first 14 years of my life I
literally never saw him because he left
at 7 A.M or 6 a.m and he came home at 10
p.m and he worked seven days a week how
many people here are immigrants or
children of immigrants raise your hands
awesome so this group that just raised
their hands they know that immigrants in
America have absolutely figured out one
of the core Secrets which is you know
work your face off and don't buy dumb
foreign
and so that's kind of what my family did
for seven or eight years you know we my
dad wasn't making that much money but if
anything happens when you buy nothing
but food at the lowest possible price
and uh save save save save save and very
quickly only six years after Coming To
America with 100 bucks my dad was able
to buy a small liquor store in New
Jersey we moved to New Jersey that is
where my entrepreneurial career began uh
when I was six I had a five Lemonade
Stand franchise
I uh manipulated my friends into
standing behind the lemonade all day and
that is when I became obsessed with
attention and this is really interesting
as you can see up here I day trade
attention culture and build businesses
at six years old
I would spend my summer days literally
walking up and down the streets of New
Jersey sitting down on the curb watching
cars drive by so that I could figure out
which tree or post was better for me to
put a sign that said lemonade a quarter
that is DNA that's like somebody singing
That's like somebody throwing a pitch
really like that is just pure DNA I
didn't read a Seth Godin book or go to
Harvard Business School to figure out
that attention was the number one asset
the one thing that combines every person
here from the cameramen back there who
are producing to the industry that is in
this room to me to Mickey to anybody
else that sneaked in the one thing that
fundamentally connects all of us is
before you tell me how great your
product and services you need my
attention so that I listen I am obsessed
with attention I am obsessed with this
device because it has the attention I am
unemotional if it's ruining the kids and
they don't know how to engage or that
you were sad that people go out to
dinner and don't talk to each other
technology does not care about your
feelings
and so I as a human may have some
opinions about Parenthood and society
and privacy as a human
but as a businessman I am unemotional
and not romantic all I do is follow
where the attention is and I figure out
how to storytell in there to create the
action that I desire say a couple things
number one you have to find a way to
genuinely appreciate yourself for your
strengths and your shortcomings
stunningly attractive some people
there's about 32 guys tonight here in
Dallas that are about to get drafted
that were remarkably athletic you know I
wasn't either one of those two and like
that's okay but I know how to sell stuff
and I'm a good guy and like you know to
me what I would say to people is
judgment you're placing on yourself was
created through either a combination of
DNA or the way that you were brought up
and you need to spend time with
optimistic positive people
that aren't judging you to break out of
that framework glass half full
is a terrible way
you know excuse me glass half empty is a
terrible way to live life
like looking at everything and being
pessimistic
is the worst thing that could happen to
you and you should do everything in your
power whether that is going and seeing
somebody whether that is changing your
friends whether that is abruptly getting
up and moving to Peru for the rest of
your life whatever you have to do to get
out of a place where you go negative
is something you have to figure out
whether you have to listen I'm not a
doctor but whether you have to get
medicated whether you have to like like
what my biggest thing is who do you
spend time with and who do you consume
and this is my biggest point to
everybody this is why I don't allow
complaining or dwelling for people that
want to [__] with me because no matter
what I'm going to point to somebody who
had the same exact same oh what you had
a crackhead father and your and your mom
[__] sexually abused you and you got
stabbed cool let me show you this kid
who actually had that exact same thing
and he won like what we're talking about
right now is the reason I win I'm not
worried about the little details this is
all macro blueprint strategy mental
strategy no matter what we say right now
Pete I'm going to show you somebody who
grew up with the same exact situation
have different outcomes and so for me
everybody who's dwelling on their
shortcoming the bottom line is no matter
where you start everybody has paths to
winning and losing
for me the best move is to take control
of your no matter how [__] up you are
right now get rid of loser friends and
family introduce yourself to positivity
and winners and watch how it plays out
looking for short-term highs
you know when when the game itself and
the process and gratitude is the mix of
your gasoline you'll run forever when
it's about getting a watch or buying a
new home or getting a new pair of Yeezys
you're finished and so I see a lot of
people looking for quick highs I want to
get that girl I want to get that guy I
want to get that plane I want to get
that you know car that is just not
sustainable when you're like I cannot
believe I'm alive thank you so much and
oh my God I can't wait to wake up and
fight and grind and try to win I love
the game you're unstoppable
never run out of energy because
things never run out the game's forever
and gratitude's forever trying to figure
out how to get this for everybody
because it is the I think it's the
ultimate I lived in my own head nobody
had say when I tell you nobody had say
still to this day nobody has say nobody
has say very early on there was only one
voice in my game my own it's so scary to
me how singular my own voice is it
doesn't mean that I don't listen to
feedback it doesn't mean that I'm
delusional and I think I can get away
with bad and it's all okay I could say
something right now in this podcast
everybody on Earth says I'm a piece of
[__] and in my own mind I'm like we'll
see
it's very strange How I Live Life
it's it's way more extreme than you
think it's way more extreme than I think
I'm just like kind of like going through
it right now I'm like what the [__] this
is crazy like it just means that I am
incapable of valuing anybody else's
opinion including my mom's
my wives and my children's opinion about
me over my own if you realized how much
of the actions you do is to show
your mom or your dad or your sibling or
your spouse or somebody show somebody
else that you made it or you did it it
is remarkably scary how many people are
dictated by somebody else's opinion I'm
secretly worried that I'm gonna get to a
place where I'm not gonna care anything
about business and it's the love of my
life but I can like feel it already I'm
like
you know 55 to 75 is going to be some
run
when you actually believe in the value
you're providing
selling promoting
giving for free when you believe
it all clicks the reason people don't do
is because they don't believe they uh
either are insecure and structured that
way or they deep down know they're doing
it for the money
how many people like did things for me
with expectation
a ton and most of the times I'll say no
because I don't even want to do that but
once in a while I say yes
mainly to stick it to them and teach
them A Life Lesson which is don't come
at me and be like I want to do this
awesome thing for you
and then kind of hover around and always
have this weird relationship with me
where they expect something like we did
something here like if you told me up
front that the reason you bought ten
thousand books and did this thing was
because what you really wanted was my
face on your website co-signing your
business well then you should have told
me
because then we could have had a
transaction a lot of your advice geared
to like college grad yep but I'm old I'm
40. what would you like what would your
voice advice be for someone who's 40 but
starting out where most of your audience
is starting out when they're 20 or 30.
well it's interesting no joke I don't
know if you saw this I literally posted
a video today to 47 year olds
I did not see that yet so uh to me
everybody's going through different
things you know I to your point in the
last eight 12 to 18 months I found
myself producing a lot more content to
youth than I have in the past which was
usually to more 40 year old business
people
um look I think the biggest thing with
40 to 50 is that it's now you've lived
life and you're still young as
and you're like now what right you have
like an entire second life to live and
it's a very interesting time in people's
lives where they have to be really
retrospective of like how self-aware are
they but honestly I think 40s young man
I really really do and so I would say a
lot of the advice I give to 20 year olds
Maps pretty well to 40 year olds which
is you know take some risks you've
tasted some stuff you know happiness is
the ROI and so you know figure out what
makes you happy is it the pursuit of
money or is it actual money do materials
make you happy if materials make you
happy is that really just insecurity and
you need to have you know a BMW to make
yourself feel good like what's making
you tick but I would say the biggest
thing that I would tell any 40 year old
is you've got 50 years to live please
get the I'm finished or I [__] up like
eliminate dwelling because you're just
starting I really believe that by the
way this is not some motivational
rah-rah I just think it's true I just
think you've got 40 adult years to live
that's 20 more than you've lived there's
just so much opportunity
I just launched a platform for
connecting companies with social media
influencers okay like a Tinder
self-direct and I thought I had kind of
a unicorn and now I'm kind of exploring
the world I say okay there's a lot out
there so everybody's doing it but we're
kind of late here in this part of the
world yep so here I captured the markets
really well in a short time that's
awesome but I wonder how my dreams about
internationalization and getting Global
and making it scalable making it bigger
what advice would you give to me for
that well a couple things first of all
how big is it in the market that you're
winning in
it the biggest thing that you know like
unless you're doing 7 10 12 million
dollars in the nordics you should not be
thinking about Eastern Western Europe
U.S too many people like every word out
of your mouth is this I was just taught
like scalable what like we're just all
caught up in building billion dollars
it's so stupid like how big is your
company how much are you doing over a
million hours we are pretty rare than
you yeah I mean we just launched it
until you money you shouldn't be worried
about global no
so some local markets go that way
vaynermedia did 75 million dollars in
Revenue profitably before I thought
about even going to London okay
everybody's caught listen I'm telling
you all of you you're caught up in
propaganda you're not thinking about it
smartly you make no money and you're
sitting here worried about winning
globally and you haven't even started
winning locally
you understand yeah I'm just thinking
like it's partnership the way to go to
somebody that are old no the way to go
is to not think about it at all what I
tell people to do is get the leverage
you know let them go to your Instagram
and see 10 000 people there in an active
Community let them hear that you're
selling out every time you have a new
thing then they're going to come to you
the thing I do extremely well all the
fancy people every fancy person you've
ever seen me with any anyone Tony The
Rock anyone anyone I've never reached
out to them let everything come to you
all of them I've hit that kind of quiet
Crescendo moment where like it just I'm
so in tune with like putting out content
putting it out there letting you guys
consume it reading your feedback in this
viral Loop and just feels like I'm in
that zone and every day I wish for you
guys out there in the world to find that
same Zone and so look for that thing
find that thing and for me this
community is that thing and I want to
thank you from the bottom of my heart
thank you so much have the best best
rest of the weekend have the best summer
flip start things produce content but
most of all listen you know the audacity
that everybody wants likes and comments
and subscribers but doesn't want to then
do for them what they want to return the
selfishness of like give me vanity
metrics and social and content and
digital yet the key is if you listened
and cared about those individuals as
much as what you wanted from them and
likes and subscribers everything would
be different please do not take things
for granted and most of all do not take
your Community for granted because it's
the foundation of your opportunity in
this Digital World the reason I say the
thing that if there's anybody that ever
looked like you that made it then
there's no excuse is because I believe
it
you know it's really hard you're in an
argument and that your friend tells you
that's great Gary but both my parents
were alcoholics
and that really [__] me up right now
you're on the defense that's a good
first punch by them
I'm like cool we don't need to use me
if anybody has ever been successful that
had two alcoholic parents which by the
way I know of three
well then now what's your excuse Karen
we are just so interested in blaming
everybody else
and excuses because we don't want to
take on responsibility
and somewhere a long time ago I went
completely I only I you know I think
everything is my fault
like all of it like I think it's weirdly
cloudy outside right now and not nice
out my fault
like his scar my fault like I just
default into my fault
and everybody tries to do everything
else the other way and let me tell you
how good life becomes when you take on
responsibility
it gets real good uh some of you and
there's a lot of you that follow me you
know why I keep bringing up the last
scene of eight mile the Eminem movie how
many people have seen that movie
great
the last scene they go into the battle
he makes fun of himself the whole time
because it leaves the other person with
nothing
The Leverage is in being accountable of
everything The Leverage is exposing your
weaknesses I proudly talk about passing
on Uber twice being a dnf student you
know I proudly talk about my
shortcomings right I can't wait for more
bad things to happen we are in a
remarkable time for all the things you
may be worried about left right up down
there's never been a better time to be
alive in the human race than right now
medicine life expectancy poverty every
issue we have better
you know the best people to talk about
what's going on in America are 90 year
olds they [__] on everybody
she thinks it's bad
this woman made me laugh so hard it's
like 92 year old woman stop me in the
street she's like keep doing what you're
doing I'm like I mean she looked like
190.
I was like thank you I gotta talk to him
for a second she's like and by the way
these women and she's wrong but it was
still funny I'm obsessed with
practicality
people think I'm a disrupter or uh you
know uh nostradamic predictor or right
unpractical
Facebook and Instagram ads are grossly
underpriced if you go home tonight and
Google how to run Instagram story ads
and learn how to do that and then make a
video or picture and run Instagram story
ads for whatever you're trying to do in
life become the mayor Here Sell some
peanuts kombucha get people to sign up
for your you know track team I don't
care what I don't know where the [__]
comes from
I don't even think you can sign people
up for a track team anyway nonetheless
an Instagram story ad will work better
than anything else you can do if you
care about people 15 to 55.
15 to 45. if you care about people 30 to
75 Facebook works better than anything
like all your dreams
whatever that may be
simple dreams like making 400 more a
month so you can save it and take your
family to Walt Disney this year all your
dreams like
the amount of people that are affected
by making 200 more a month is staggering
the fact that I know that if you
literally stop listening to me right now
took out your phone went to Craigslist
went to the for sale Section clicked on
the free section within the for sale
Section took the car got up left in the
middle of my keynote and picked up eight
things went home took one picture on
your phone not like old days phone you
picked a discount on the computer no not
that which is oh by the way the old days
you know 11 years ago and no just take a
picture of the thing and post it on
Facebook Marketplace and post it for 20
to 80 that literally in the next 48
hours you would have 200 more
I'm obsessed with practicality
everything I talk about feels so real it
just might take 11 years
and a lot of people don't have 11 years
they don't have 11 years because they're
not willing to put in the work to be
happy for the rest of their life they'd
rather complain
they'd rather blame somebody else what
are the qualities that you think make
for a true and a successful entrepreneur
what's important uh she or he has to
love the game
for me a purebred entrepreneur she or he
loves the journey
not the stuff you know one of the things
I struggle with in the current state of
Entrepreneurship is a lot of people want
the
vacations the watches you know even even
the context of this you guys have such
an incredible imagery I think it's
remarkable who doesn't want fine things
in life yeah but I think that if you're
in the game just for the fine things in
life for the bottles and the models and
the private planes I think you're gonna
lose and it definitely is not my
definition of an entrepreneur my
definition of an entrepreneur is
somebody who can't live without doing
their thing and trying to create
literally suffocated people quit all the
time because they're doing it for the
money I think the bigger question is
what do you want the money for is it
blocking the insecurities that to get
the girl is it is it is because you're
trying to mass as much as you can
because you don't actually don't like
working and you want to live the reason
so many people fail in life in business
is their model is let me get the money
so that I can enjoy and relax they think
of it as like hoarding it and then
eating it all over time it's like
retirement and all this it's such a bad
way to because then you're feeling the
pressure of like massing so that you can
then enjoy I think the bigger question
is like what are you up to like why are
you doing it like what's up I just think
a lot of people are trying to achieve
success
you've got to break out of that pattern
you gotta not listen to him and make
money
however way you want
listen otherwise you're stuck if you
want to help your mom sometimes the best
way to help your mom is to get out and
then come back and get her out
I get it so honestly honestly and I
respect that listen to me life is long
right now but my mom didn't have her mom
or dad for a TV Mike was wrong it's such
right now if when you're 14 it feels
like it's your life forever it's not
your light forever bro you understand
surround yourself with as much
positivity to get you through this
I have no friends I get it bro bro you
gotta be patient it's early
forever
I get it but you have to understand
there's no alternative there's only two
choices here you stay under that roof
and each four more years three more
years two more years or you bounce now
plenty of people bounce to 14. it's not
common in the UK but people do it or you
don't life's about a very simple option
if you're gonna
under that roof you need to put your
pods in and listen to positivity 24 7
again you understand when your
surroundings are your insides got to be
positive the fact that you're even here
means you're halfway home
[Music]
but you have no choice you either bounce
or you stay and if you stay which is
more likely which is fine you gotta put
positivity in your ears do you
understand I promise you you have no
other Alternatives otherwise you just
dwell and you go down a spiral that you
don't want to go down you understand
this whole notion of like you can do
anything and all this stuff let me just
tell you it's stupid hard
reality is most of you are just
averagely talented
right like you're not going to over
index in anything too crazy here's the
good news this is not about how much
money you make or how talented you are
this is about being happy everybody here
regardless of how
talented they are in making money or art
or what have you has that they're super
into you love Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles
your whole life could be about
Michelangelo
it could and here's what really with me
in this internet age you could have a
podcast around Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles you could buy Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtle memorabilia on Craigslist
and Facebook and Etsy and then flip it
on a different platform because you're
so eligible because that's the pizza
eating Leonardo
[Laughter]
that I'm just fascinated about what
happens when you go all in on your
passion you're committed to it and you
use the infrastructure of this you
living your life for 80 years as the
Teenage Ninja Turtle expert is getting
funnier to me by the second
making 83k a year in ads on your podcast
the flip some miraculous reason somebody
paid you two thousand dollars to go to a
bush League Comic-Con thing
that person making 62 000 a year being
the PMT expert versus them making 77 000
a year being an admin in a company where
they hate their life nine to five that
Delta is something I will go to the
Grave on because it is what I want to
articulate to everybody the The
Unbelievable level of practicality to do
[__] around stuff you like and here's
the big part
how many people under 40
let me just start with this group
if you just really took what I'm talking
about became an expert at Facebook and
Instagram really understood the fact
that you could take a leap for two years
move back in home move in together cut
your expenses I don't give it the fact
that you can do that for two or three
years and if it doesn't work out you can
go back
to getting a job that's nuts I don't
think you get to judge what somebody
does with the fruits
of their labor yeah uh for me I think
that that's what's amazing about
anything which is there's many different
uh many different uh definitions for you
uh you know go out work your face off
win and reward yourself with something
is exactly right for me the reward is
pouring more of the dollars and energy
into the company not buying stuff for
myself it's one and the same to me I I
think it's amazing if somebody wants to
buy an Armani suit or a five thousand
dollar pair of belt or a diamond ring
for a hundred thousand I don't but that
doesn't mean that's right or wrong what
I'm doing with that same hundred
thousand instead of a ring is I'm hiring
two more people because I'm trying to
buy the jewelry company not a piece of
the jewelry the biggest vulnerability
everybody has here is they're worried
about somebody else's judgment
the reason there is no Moment of clarity
is you don't want to jump
you don't want to jump because you're
worried if you lose what people are
going to say starting with your parents
your friends your contemporaries my
ability to not truly truly care about
other people's opinions
has been the foundation of my happiness
I respect people's opinions
I just I just don't care about their
judgment of me
I I have flip-flopped about project
management at vaynermedia like so many
times and I don't worry if somebody
hears like make a decision or like
you're stupid or like what the [__] or
why are we always change it like
go work it great advertising the reason
I will never achieve my goals is my
goals are to play
the reason people achieve their goals is
because their goals was a number of
money
if your goal is an amount of money
you've lost
so the reason it's empty is what you
wanted to be a millionaire so what
happens next you're going to make 10
million a year like what 100 million
like it's the wrong goals my biggest
goals is to be the most impactful
entrepreneur of this generation by
bringing the most value to all the
entrepreneurs that's going to take me my
whole life
thank you so you need to change your
goal from something that's selfish to
something that's selfless because then
it will take you the rest of your life
you should really go to a retirement
home one day and volunteer and just talk
to them it will make you want to every
minute of your life because when you're
90 and you're not mobile and you're
tired and it's over
you can't do it you can't do it you
can't build that company you wanted you
can't spend that time with your kid it's
regret
yeah and it drives how old are you I'm
27 27. you got time it's a it's a
balance of regret and patience like you
can go hard on for three years do
nothing right wake up and be youngest
the amount of people who are watching
this right now maybe even in this room
that are sad men and women that they
didn't go for it and didn't make the
move and didn't try that regret is a
hell of a lot longer and more painful
and more drawn out than the instant
rejection of going for it it's just the
way it is like even if you think of
random dumb stuff like not asking out
that person in high school or something
this stuff lingers it's the stuff that
you don't do that bothers you and so for
the purebred entrepreneurs in here that
haven't decided to make that leap or
take that at-bat I implore you to do so
right away because this window closes
too Evan thank you so much for having a
couple seconds and being able to tell
the believe Nation a little bit about
empathy wines it means a lot to me that
you would take this valuable real estate
and and time on your channel to give me
some love means a lot it's just good
karma points and so you're just you're
awesome thank you believe Nation uh if
you're into wine at all go to
empathywines.com my whole careers work
was poured into producing a wine that
rivaled 40 to 60 wine for 20 bucks a
bottle uh I'm just super excited about
this subscription-based wine business
you can order three six or 12 bottles in
subscription form Rose white red
um if you if you search on Instagram or
Twitter you will be blown away people
are literally like I don't even like
garyvee but the line's good super proud
of the effort thanks Evan for the time
uh wishing you guys all happy and
healthy because you made it this far in
a video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you may it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome
if you want another amazing Gary
vaynerchuk video check it out right
there next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there